am donnerstag sind im
niederösterreichischen malick szenen zu
beobachten
die man nicht alle tage zu sehen bekommt
schweres militärisches gerät schwimmt
auf der donau
ja wir versuchen mit einem doch etwas
länger gebraucht stellt eine faire gerät
den moderneren
gewichtsklassen der neuen kampffahrzeuge
gerecht zu werden und haben da versucht
durch eine vergrößerte bauform auch
moderne kampfpanzer und
transportsysteme unrein gewässer
transportieren zu können das war das
ziel das amt für rüstung und wehrtechnik
kurzer erwitt testet eine transport
fähre auf ihre belastbarkeit über 100
tonnen gewicht sollte sie tragen können
notwendig geworden ist diese erprobung
wegen internationaler entwicklungen es
ist so dass unser gerät verlängern
gebraucht stellt aber es gibt auch im
internationalen bereich wieder
bestrebungen die
bewegungsfähigkeit von truppenteilen zu
erhöhen es ist so dass aufgrund auch
gewisser spannungsverhältnisse bei den
baltischen staaten auch immer plato dass
das überqueren von größeren gewässern
wieder ein thema wurde und in unserem
bereich war das sonst so dass wir auch
darüber nachgedacht haben ob wir denn in
der lage werden auch moderne kampfpanzer
mit einer durchaus ausgeprägten
schutzausstattung heben in dieser
gewichtsklasse bis 85 tonnen ob wir
dienen auch in der lage werden über ein
gewässer zu bringen die antwort ist ja
selbst zwei leopard-kampfpanzer schafft
die fähre problemlos trainer dieser
kampfpanzer hat nahezu 55 tonnen das
heißt miteinander stellen wird 110
tonnen auf die fähre das wäre mir ist
das von mir angesprochene prüft gewicht
damit ich als technik auch sagen kann
dass eine sicherheitsreserve ausreichend
vorhanden um es im truppendienst
freigeben zu können die gefahr dass bei
diesem test etwas schief gehen könnte
ist rein rechnerisch aber gegen null
gehen muss ich natürlich sagen auch die
wir selber dem berechnet man angestellt
haben dafür aber sagen dass ich schon
mit einer gewissen erleichterung auch
die
das hat nicht mal zulassungsdaten mit 21
prozent übergewicht bereits hinter mich
gebracht habe